looks as simple
right if
you're not the best version of yourself
and
i'll tell you why it's so simple guys it
this boggles my mind what is it like 50
60 something percent of the north
american population is categorically
unhealthy
obese morbidly obese fat whatever
category you want to put it in you're
not fit
you're getting out of the shower you're
looking down and you don't see your
johnson or your feet because it's
covered in belly fat or your man boobs
or both right
looks matters women want to be with an
attractive guy they want to be with a
guy that looks good i covered this in my
book
right here the 1.62 golden ratio is
measured from shoulder to waist they
want a v taper if you want to accentuate
it like an overly exaggerated version of
what that looks like johnny bravo
old you know back in the day cartoon
character that's why they v tapered him
like that that's of course not
physically possible that's an
exaggeration because it's a cartoon
character but you get the idea women
want to see a guy with broader shoulders
and a narrower waist they don't want to
be with a guy that's shaped like a pear
but most guys they'll come in oh yeah
i'm red pillar i get it i understand
looks money status solipsism hypergamy
okay i got it yeah she's not yours it's
just your turn okay women wait at the
finish line to pick the winner got it
god i got it they get all that
information and then they get out of the
shower and they still look down and they
can't see their feet or the johnson and
they're putting on weight and they're
not doing anything about the way they
look they don't go to the gym and by the
way you know
these spokes again it's not just you
know like the one spoke over there these
things can be divided off when you look
at a bicycle spoke there's usually like
i think it's
somewhere between five to seven spokes
that kind of like fork off in different
directions and triangle out and they do
that for for strength reasons but
something in a looks department for
example you could tie in self-care you
know you could tie in lifestyle habits
you could tie in competency skills like
fighting one of the things that um
you know is so funny and i did this too
like okay like i was a poster boy i'm
being completely honest with you
for years i trained i lift weights
deadlifts bench press squatting i could
put three plates on bench them no
problem for reps you know squat a bunch
of plates no problem do all that stuff i
was strong very strong in fact
but
i realized one day and nobody really
messed with me like i'd go to bars and
nightclubs and nobody ever really you
know pick fights with me just just
because i was a bigger guy right
but then i realized one day well what
happens if i do have to fight what
happens if the needs called upon me
where i got to raise fists and do
something do i know how to deal with it
when i said you know i started looking
into it it's like okay well let me go to
a dojo and i'll start talking these guys
and i got into krav maga and now i've
switched more over to boxing and stuff
and it's like
i started messing with guys at the dojo
that were 100 pounds lighter than me and
smaller than me that showed me that
just focus energy it doesn't matter if
you're big and strong like you know if
you got like the bodybuilder sort of
look or even like a swimmer's body women
want the swimmer's body by the way they
don't want the bodybuilder look
generally speaking they want more of a
thinner tone muscular sort of build so
think guys like michael phelps for
example
i thought myself this this little dude
is able to manipulate me and basically
fold me into a pretzel when
you know the other day i was at the gym
you know benching three plates you see
what i'm saying right so it's like you
know all of these things kind of like
like funnel out into different areas
sort of thing if you know what i'm
saying
okay
looking at the chat you guys are really
lighting this one up today guys do me a
solid if you're enjoying the cast just
hit the like button okay we've got a lot
we got hundreds of people watching i got
178 likes right now you know it doesn't
cost anything just hit the like button
if you're enjoying the cast so we talked
about looks competently skill fighting
you know
self-care um mindfulness you know as far
as meditation getting focused you know
getting your sleep right all of these
things kind of tie into that spoke that
might you know filter out a difference
money
you know
i kind of hit on this earlier but i was
talking about this at one point i think
was a year ago and then out of nowhere
you know because i said something like
there's all this money that's flowing
through the internet every single day
and all you got to do is create some
value and reach out there and grab some
of it
and oh boy didn't the sulking little
whiny little come at me with
richard's so out of touch he doesn't
understand he's got the money but he
doesn't understand how hard is it making
you can't
i'm at
fine be poor i don't care
it's like when i talk about
cryptocurrency i've been saying it for
years get crypto buy bitcoin buy
ethereum understand layer 1 solutions
look at smart contracts get your head up
head around it that's a ponzi scheme
it's not going anywhere yeah man
looks money so we talked about money so
much of it out there
who said it earlier this week ed
vladimir i have ed ed latimer he's a
retired heavyweight boxer i got him
lined up for uh thursday for playing the
win great guy
very very smart former alcoholic has a
lot of fascinating stories you know used
to fight and everything like that he
said earlier this week i saw his tweet i
can't i can't remember what it said
verbatim but it was something along the
lines of
if you want
if you want to have fu money
if you really want to have fu money you
need to have fu skills
because one thing doesn't go without the
other just think about that right
people that have acquired a vast amount
of wealth or money
what that translates into is a store of
of value because that's all money is
it's a store of value you go and do
something you create value somebody
gives you money that money or the
cryptocurrency whatever it happens to be
is a monetary number of value which you
can now withdraw send solve problems
somebody is a a problem for you you know
you can hire a lawyer and fix it you
have a medical issue you can pay for it
you see what i'm saying right all that
money is a store of value that you can
then deploy
to deal with problems that come up in
your life let's move on to status
oh this is going to be a this is going
to be a longer one i thought i was going
to turn and burn through this in like 20
minutes but this is going to be a long
so let's talk about status
significance again
that guy comes in he's a red pill aware
i get it cup is full 10 out of 10
understands it all looks money status
game hypergamy solidification she
doesn't care about
duh-duh-duh-duh-duh-duh waits the finish
line okay mm-hmm
it's not yours just your turn kevin from
sales steve from mechanic i got it
and then they don't fill up on the other
ones status
if you're insignificant
in life
become significant
that's really what it boils down to
that's all that it really boils down to
if you're insignificant do something of
some significance with your life now not
everybody's going to do that i
understand somebody's going to say right
now but rich not everybody can be
significant we can't all be significant
well you can be as significant as you
possibly can be depending on where you
live and what your skills are don't tell
me you can't go up one two or three
points better than where you are right
now
you're lying you're lying to me and
you're lying to yourself if you're gonna
tell me that nonsense
you know
i got an email earlier today
from this dude and um
he said something like hey what's
crackalackin rich i'm so and so and i
help you book
big names in the podcasting world
what's what's crack of lacking rich i
thought that was hilarious anyway so i
opened up the email because of the
what's crackalackin
and i read it and i was like he's got
pictures of like these three guys that
that he interviewed on his podcast
you know this dork
two of them i wouldn't touch with the
10-year 10-foot pole because they're
and then the other one i mean if i
wanted to i could pick up the phone or i
could dm him and i could say hey man you
know let's do a collab
what's crackalackin rich you know let's
get some status going on that's what
doors open when you have status right i
can reach out to a heavyweight boxer
that's retired like ed latimer and say
yo dude let's you know it's
collaborative podcast you know we said
hell yeah let's do it
right i got pd mangan lined up as well a
couple weeks from now i got this dude
that right now i've got to record this
tomorrow because he's sailing across the
mediterranean to the canary islands
and he's not going to be with an
internet connection for a while so i got
to record this i'm going to have to
release it later but you get my point
right like when you have some social
status when you have some influence you
can reach out to people and they will
respond
i got a big less big list of names over
here on my whiteboard you can't see it
in the uh the camera the camera's
managed so i can't turn it but i've
easily got
20 30 i've got about 45 different names
there
of people that i've got on my hit list
for my plane to win podcast the playing
win podcast
it's just on youtube right now so you
can't find it on on spotify so
once once i get it to the point where
the views
make sense for me to pay my guy to put
it on podcast platforms you'll find it
over there so tune in for it on youtube
for now but status does matter guys
status creates option for you you know
i've said before
your network is your net worth
i'm gonna say it again your network is
your net worth
you could strip
you could strip a guy like elon musk of
his billions of dollars
and
his his companies his space his solar
panel his rockets all that you
could remove all of that stuff
and pick him up and drop him on another
continent as long as he's got his roll
of death i'm using rolodex as a term
it's an old term for for you young ones
out there who don't understand so i'm
dating myself but as long as he's got
his contact list on his phone let's say
and he needed to reach out to somebody
anybody they would respond to him so
your network is your network that's what
status means okay
significant
let's move on to frame um i'm gonna drop
the
link again to
call-ins so copy so guys if you're
watching this somewhere else on the
internet you're gonna have to come over
to youtube because i don't deploy it
everywhere i'm just gonna put it on
youtube and then pin it to the top
call in and ask a question
live or if you have a share um
maf i see in the in the uh the chat if
you want to share anything on tonight's
topic uh by all means
uh calling
and doom and let me pin that up to the
top
pin message
all right it's up there so if you guys
want to chime in or ask a question
tonight
i'll get to that in a second you just
start clicking through
um
let's talk about status quo status let's
talk about game
game is important so
red pill awareness is one thing in my
view
okay
game is the execution of said knowledge
that's what a lot of these doomers do
right they'll show up
they'll go all dark i hate this isn't
fair women are hypergames
okay and they don't do any of the work
and they'll never move to a playing game
they'll never move to like dude
i was at the bank the other day and i
was gaming
you know the banker right
to get what i needed done
i'll do it on the phone you know if i'm
on the like i had to uh the sticker for
my uh plate
it got lost
and they have these stupid rules and
you got to dance around i'm gaming
around the phone you know get the
sticker right
game is more is not just useful to get
girls to get a date to
be intimate with her game is useful in
business transactions it's it's useful
in a lot of different things and if you
don't use the skill
on a regular basis in your life it's
going to decay you're not going to hone
it you're not going to master it again
and hold it up if you guys are coming in
late to the show these spokes in the
wheel they matter you can you can have a
full tank here on red pill awareness but
if you're missing all the other ones the
spoke never makes full contact you're
not a 10 out of 10 in that area and
wheels don't rotate properly if the
spokes aren't all in place you're going
to get results with that
that's what most guys do and then
they're just like ah i'm out
it's not fair
i feel this is another one that bugs me
and i had to rip somebody in my
community earlier today because he
started whinging and wanting well i feel
like ben's smv should peak at this point
instead of this point you know what i
don't care what you feel i dm them i
don't care what you feel okay
your feelings don't matter
the reality of it all is if you do the
work and you level up by the time you
get to your mid to late 30s you're at
your smv max's dude okay i don't care
what you feel that's the reality of it
that's how people operate that's how it
works
but i feel like it should be this way
instead
i feel like she should just like me for
who i am
slide them all the way down the other
end of the scale over to the point extra
side
that's what these guys believe right
game see a few guys waiting there in the
area give me a give me a couple minutes
make sure your cameras are on guys
because uh
i am only taking the inbounds from guys
when your cameras are on and if you can
tell me in the private chat there's a
little private chat there let me know
what it is you want to talk about too
just so i can sort through everybody's
requests to join i only have so much
time um
frame is the application of game
in a relationship
generally over
a period of time it could be a friends
with benefits it could be a plate could
be a girlfriend open exclusive could be
a wife open exclusive depending on how
it is you want to run run your life but
frame is the control
of that relationship
rollo's number one rule it's all about
frame
in every relationship one person enters
the other person's frame
okay
when somebody tries to take the frame
away from you let it happen
better tization through a thousand
concession starts to occur
you have to apply it
red pill awareness is one thing
game is another
that's the actual application frame you
know it's a very close spoke to that
frame is something that you're going to
apply
when dealing with women
over over a period of time over a term
could be short medium long term doesn't
matter
make sure you're always operating in
your frame she's in your frame is
basically what i'm saying
and then the captivation part which i
talked about again
captivation
just don't be boring guys that's that's
really what it just boils down to don't
be boring don't be
basic don't be
and you know what
one of the chapters of my book again i
covered i talk about motorcycles
motorcycles like were the easiest way
for me in my 20s i rode bikes from about
17 18 i think it was all the way up to
30ish
so the vast majority of my 20s you know
i spent riding fast motorcycles i didn't
really get into fast cars until
i started to move away from bikes but
they're very cheap you can buy you can
buy a nice bike for like seven eight
thousand dollars they're not expensive
they get they're incredibly fast they
get great gas mileage the way that
they're laid out it literally forces her
to be intimate with you she's gotta hold
on to your waist okay she's not going to
hold onto bars when you're accelerating
or you know flying around canyons are
going fast she's going to hold on to
your waist it forces intimacy
okay it's exciting you're in full
control she has to trust you
she has to give you 100 of her trust
to get on the back of a bike and believe
that
you know her life will be safe with you
and she's going to be scared
of course because
what could happen somebody could hit you
you could be a terrible writer and wipe
out so there's an element of fear
that comes into that equation as well
which is actually a good thing right you
don't want women feeling too comfortable
all the time
right there has to be some surprise
there has to be something interesting
going on and you know again i'm just
using this motorcycle exam this is just
one example of many that we can possibly
use but a motorcycle is a exciting thing
doesn't cost you a lot of money to get
into it forces intimacy
it's cheap mode of transportation cheap
on gas super fast
there's amazing social groups and
networks that you can get into you got
nothing going on your world but work and
going to the gym every once in a while
and you're still on the poindexter scale
get a motorcycle your life will improve
dramatically overnight i promise you
your smv will go up at least one point
by getting a cool motorcycle and then
starting to use it and interacting with
other people and hanging out in social
groups making friends going to the
coffee shop hanging on the ramps there
was this one section in toronto
for those of you that live in toronto
will know this but the shepherd dvp
ramps were basically this big figure
eight of um
loops that you could basically ride as
long as you wanted to just the way they
structure the ramps and you know we used
to go there and hang off the bikes and
go back and get the coffees and there
was girls there sometimes sometimes we
bring girls sometimes it was just the
bros but it's exciting it's interesting
and that's all that the captivation part
means is just be interesting just do
something fun it doesn't have to be
bikes figure out whatever that other
thing looks like i'm just using that as
an example right it's it's a placeholder
right if you want to learn more about
that again guys grab the book on amazon
unplugged alpha it's in kindle print and
audible i narrated it myself it's worth
its weight in gold grab it
you